at what point in time did you first like
start getting familiar with the street
[ __ ] like was like at what age
like 13 13 so that's what at least
because that's when i started like
getting hungry like and wanting things
i'm like
[ __ ] i can't really eat like this or do
something like this so i gotta get on
the streets and i gotta make it happen
bruh i gotta i gotta make something i
gotta do something right charlie man's
man young trying to sell crack for a
short amount of time that [ __ ] died out
quick cause like that was the ending
error and they got the crack area yeah i
wasn't in the 80s
when it was popping so you know i'm [ __ ]
early early 2000s just catching some
stragglers like it wasn't really
something super crazy i feel like what
what was after that i feel like
[ __ ] were good listen to me bro
i always been good with [ __ ] and when
i saw like it was just even just having
them just around like just always having
like him saying so i just started like
kind of pressing like hey let's do this
or you know i'm saying you want to get
on it and a lot of [ __ ] already be
down they already was ready to ride
that's crazy and then from there it was
like i found my my niche i found yeah i
felt like it you know i felt like it was
something i could do oh can i do this
forever but then i start getting older
bro and just
you grow man like you know i just start
getting older man and just start like
[ __ ] man i know i got to come up with
some type of game plan and this ain't
even [ __ ] like a podcast or nothing
like i don't give a [ __ ] if it's just
owning a business owning something i'm
saying doing anything i don't give a
[ __ ] podcasting was the last
[ __ ] thing on the list
you're so great at it man i just uh
i touched the microphone and i ain't
left yet